Transcription: Trask Roberts
Relecteur: eric vautier
Repartir à zéro.
J'écris pour repartir à zéro.
J’ai mon enfance entre les bras,
j’ai mon  enfance entre les bras
et elle me serre contre elle
comme si j’allais m’envoler dans le ciel,
comme si l’amour donnait des ailes,
comme si on était éternel.
Repartir à zéro.
Renaître tous les jours
et ne pas faire son âge.
La peur de n’être à jamais qu’un narrateur
et pas un personnage.
Au fil des lettres, au fil des mots,
j'aimerais tellement repartir à zéro.
Repartir à zéro.
Le temps a fait de nos vies un tableau.
Certains l'admirent.
Certains le haïssent.
Moi, j'essaie juste de comprendre
ce que tout ça veut dire.
J’essaye de me taire,
de me retirer du monde,
de trouver les mots
que les gens n’ont pas.
Transformer une réalité,
transposer des émotions,
créer des métaphores
avec nos espaces vides.
J’écris pas pour exprimer
ce que j’ai dans la tête.
J’écris pour découvrir
ce qu’il y a dans ma tête.
J’essaye de comprendre
les gens qui s’aiment.
Et puis les gens
qui s’empoisonnent eux-mêmes.
Les gens qui passent, les gens pressés,
ceux qui traînent les pieds.
Les gens qui ont un soleil dans le cœur.
Et les gens épuisés.
Les enfants.
Les adultes qui sont restés des enfants
et ceux qui ont grandi trop vite,
les malheureux de la Terre.
Ceux qui regardent ailleurs,
là où ils sont les seuls à voir.
J’écris pour ces gens étranges,
ceux qu’on appelle les rêveurs.
Ceux qui ont les yeux qui s’éteignent
et se ravivent sans cesse
comme la flamme
d’une bougie face à la tempête.
Ceux qui ne savent pas s'ils sont humains
ou s'ils sont juste différents.
Ceux qui...
Ceux qui cherchent la lumière
jusqu’au bout de la nuit,
qui regardent par la fenêtre
et qui ne voient pas le bout de la vie.
Les gens qui hurlent
à déchaîner les passions,
ceux qui cherchent des étoiles
et qui ont trouvé des constellations.
Les gens qui ne voient pas
les saisons qui défilent,
qui préfèrent perdre la raison
que perdre leur raison de vivre.
Les gens qui ne savent pas dire au revoir,
les larmes les plus sincères
sont les plus chères.
C'est pour ceux qui pleurent de l'or noir.
J’écris parce que...
J’écris parce que c’est plus fort que moi.
Tu vois, cette sensation
qui te soulève la poitrine,
à la fois remède et poison.
J'écris pour repartir à zéro.
Pour ne pas reprendre la vie
au point où je l’avais laissée.
J’écris pour retrouver cette chose
qui nous manque le plus
quand on meurt de solitude :
mon enfance.
J'ai mon enfance entre les bras.
J’ai mon enfance entre les bras
et elle me serre contre elle
comme si j’allais m’envoler dans le ciel.
Comme si l’amour donnait des ailes.
Comme si on était éternel.
Repartir à zéro.
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup.